we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's take our next caller from the
for15 area code okay caller feel free to
tell us who you are and jump right into
your question hey I've Gabriel from San
Francisco great well I'm not so I was
just wondering do your Pat watch house
of cards I'm totally hooked on it and I
was wondering how similar you think it
is to real-life washing yeah both uh
both Pat and I are watching Season 5
right now Pat's a little further ahead
of where I am yeah I've got to be honest
I'm finding myself a little bit bored
with season 5 for two reasons one I
don't think the writing is nearly as
good as in earlier seasons and let's all
be careful not to not to do any spoiling
for anybody and I'm finding it to
milquetoast compared to the Trump White
House like the things that are happening
in house of cards are not nearly as
crazy as what's happening in the White
House you know what I mean I just don't
know which is more cynical the actual
house of cards or literal White House
yeah no I know what you mean I know what
you mean and I think this is the last
season right yeah I think so season
three was really bad I was I kind of had
to just make it through that one to get
to season four which was better hmm
all right well listen we're going to
watch to the end and we'll see how it
all wraps up yeah I'm a little bit
disappointed with season 5 so far all
right Gabe thanks for the call always
great to hear from San Francisco
California we're taking calls and we
will continue taking calls after the
break